mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
wie schön waren doch die sommer und leid
mittendrin und voller emotionen und
jetzt wie wird ein sommer ohne festivals
wie wird er aussehen
außerdem die profit 19 maßnahmen werden
gelockert alle wollen so schnell wie
möglich an die arbeit zurück denn es
droht eine rezession
doch riskieren wir menschen leben um ins
normale leben zurückzukehren
obgleich wir davon ausgehen dass jeder
mensch den unendlichen wert hat können
wir natürlich keine unendlichen aufwand
betreiben um ein einzelnes menschenleben
oder des menschen leben eine bestimmte
zahl zu retten und die museen öffnen
wieder der kulturplatz ist dabei im
landesmuseum zürich
[Musik]
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz nach acht
wochen lockdown erwacht auch in unseren
gefilden wieder einiges zum leben und
das gefällt uns gut zb die museen wir
machen heute station im größten museum
der schweiz im landesmuseum in zürich
was es bedeutet ein so großes haus
wieder mit leben zu füllen hier finden
an guten tagen bis zu 2000 menschen
einlass dass er kunden hier jetzt
[Musik]
mit
die taufstelle was muss man bei auch der
ausnahmesituation
das sind die ausstellung im landesmuseum
hand da sind sie wie viel lüge die eu
stelle momentan ziehen und wir sind auch
für die insgesamt dienst im ganzen
landes muss eben sehen sie über unser
ziel platz blüht
doch so einige für das was morgen ist ja
das ist ziemlich gute nummer eigentlich
nicht ganz ehrlich ich habe aber das
freut mich
die handlung des museums mit den
lockerungen in diesen tagen nimmt der
schweizer alltag langsam wieder seinen
lauf die angst vor dem virus nimmt
weiter ab die angst vor den
wirtschaftlichen folgen der korona krise
dagegen nimmt stark zu
die frage ist was sind wir bereit zu
riskieren um zum gewohnten leben
zurückzukehren
und was gilt in dieser debatte ein
menschenleben
wir wissen nicht was sie uns bringen
werden diese tage der lockerung die
dosierte rückkehr zur normalität
eine zweite virus welle eine frage
beschäftigt uns was ist wichtiger die
schnelle rettung der arbeitsplätze oder
der verstärkte schutz der gesundheit
aller das ist sicher und wichtig auch
für moral und ich hoffe dass wir langsam
mit einer handvoll kinder gar 48 prozent
der schweizerinnen und schweizer
fürchten sich vor einer wirtschaftskrise
so die letzte srg umfrage wirtschaft
versus gesundheit diese krise so die
medizinethikerin nicola bilder an dono
zwingt uns zu einer güterabwägung wie
viel wollen und können wir für ein
menschenleben investieren ich glaube
diese abwerten können wir letztlich
nicht vermeiden
und obgleich wir davon ausgehen dass
jeder mensch unendlichen wert hat können
wir natürlich kein unendlichen aufwand
betreiben um ein einzelnes menschenleben
oder das menschenleben einer bestimmten
zahl zu retten
schon früh corona hat die
gesundheitsökonomie den wert des lebens
berechnet die lebenserwartung der
erkrankten wird dem kapital gegenüber
gestellt
für die menschliche existenz gibt es
währungen eine davon nennt sich quali
eine maßeinheit die den finanziellen
aufwand für einen medizinischen eingriff
mit den zu erwartenden lebensjahren
vergleicht wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
durch eine bestimmte maßnahme der
operation noch 40 gesunde lebensjahre
gewinne gebe nicht damit 40 collies und
jetzt kann ich das in bezug setzen zum
aufwand wenn jetzt sagen einmal die op
kostet 40 tausend franken
dann kann ich sagen okay dann kostet
mich hier ein quali 40.000 durch 40 also
1000 franken also ziemlich günstig von
daher ist die wichtige frage wie viel
können wir für ein menschenleben
aufwenden so dass die anderen menschen
darunter nicht mehr unfaire weise leiden
dh die grenze liegt da wo wir sagen
diese art vermitteln könnten wir nicht
für die anderen in gleicher weise
auffinden hunderttausend franken
so viel soll ein jahr eines geretteten
menschen lebenswert sein
das hat das bundesgericht bereits 2010
entschieden
[Musik]
da gibt es eine währung in der
gesundheitsbranche und es gibt die würde
des menschen sei unantastbar schrieb
einst der philosoph immanuel kant
für den französischen schriftsteller
michel houellebecq wird diese würden
jetzt untergraben dem französischen
radio sagte er
[Musik]
noch nie ist mit einer solchen
schamlosigkeit zum ausdruck gebracht
worden dass das leben aller menschen
nicht denselben wert hat
[Musik]
was bedeutet die menschliche würde in
corona ja damit setzt sich auch die
ethik expertin dorothea bauer
auseinander
es kann ziemlich spanisch rufen die
würde des menschen ist unantastbar das
im grundsatz wo ich wieder frostige
dänische mannschaft konvention etc oder
sich konkrete entscheidungshilfen die
ethische frage wer darf am leben bleiben
und wer muss gehen
stellt sich bei unseren nachbarn in
italien in spanien und in den usa in
aller dramatik über 80.000 menschen sind
dort wegen cupid 19 zu tode gekommen die
meisten in new york peter singer einer
der berühmtesten philosophen der welt
nimmt im interview die frage der
güterabwägung nochmals auf aber
portierte allein in den usa seien mehr
menschen an cholera gestorben als im
vietnam-krieg us soldaten im
vietnamkrieg sind vor allem junge männer
gestorben
jeder einzelne von ihnen hat mindestens
40 lebensjahre verloren
wer menschen die wegen des corona virus
sterben mehrheitlich über 65 jahre alt
sind
wir sollten jetzt fragen welche opfer
ältere menschen heute bereit sind zu
erbringen für die nachfolgenden
generationen
ich denke diese menschen wären bereit zu
sagen ich hatte ein gutes leben und klar
würde ich gerne noch ein paar jahre
leben habe ich möchte das nicht und die
kosten für die jüngeren nicht mehr
bezahlbar sind
die alten opfern sich zum wohl der
gemeinschaft ist das zumutbar zynisch
eine legitime abwägung für einen
erkrankten staat ohne soziales
auffangnetz
was ist schlimmer die krise oder die
core sprich die wirtschaftliche
rezession der wirtschaft die rezession
in den usa womöglich kein wirklich
funktionierenden sozialstaat hat der
ortslandwirt auslöser dass im endeffekt
manches leid verursachen skoda krise
jetzt als ich denke die möglichkeit
arbeiten zu können führt die arbeiten
wollen ist auch teil der menschlichen
würde harry human dignity bei uns ist
die situation viel weniger dramatisch
der staat finanziert ein sozialsystem
das in der wirtschaftlichen not zum zug
kommt
wir können und wollen uns das noch
leisten frage wo jetzt ein ufo ist mit
wirtschaftsrezession global aber nicht
weniger existenziellen das heißt wenn
wir traurig was die ethische diskussion
jetzt unmittelbar oder wert von einem
anschreiben
aber der wertvollen mann schlafe ich
habe zentrale frage die heute bekannte
von rezession wie sie immer bereit zu
machen
zum leid zu mindern und rezessionen
statt
antworten auf diese fragen zu finden das
ist die aufgabe die jetzt auf uns wartet
in zeiten mit und vor allem nach corona
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich da mit dem chefcoach
andreas spielangebot sind sehr gut danke
sie sind froh dass der betrieb wieder
aufnehmen ist es ein schock sie sollen
großen riesigen umfangs landesmuseum
verein tag auf dauer einfach an land
störe die hand so eine risikobeteiligung
mir jetzt ja anfangs pandemie risiko ist
aufgeführt aber mein gerechnet wirklich
damit gerechnet dass man vor fünf
monaten also muss er umschließt das sie
so hat sich so angefühlt dann friedlich
ab und an das jetzt haben wir aber im
unterschied zur ein
privatwirtschaftlicher betrieb grüßt
dass es bloße existenz bedrohend ich
will mir haben die kreis konkursrisiko
vita sieben private betrieb weiterhin
kann sie trotzdem ist er krisen
management stamme ja der hand natürlich
auch ertrag mit einem monat für monat
und rechner oder nur die narkose
natürlich für halbe million ist das pro
monat und das ist schon
besorgniserregend wie reagiert man
darauf anziehe werde das jetzt über zwei
millionen fällt
das ist doch ziemlich viel was sind denn
da konsequenter darum bemühen dass mit
dieser veranstaltung
könnte aber fahren also darauf
verzichten und wirke das markus stähli
gefährlichen reduzieren andere weg
förderung also in dem bereich wie muss
man sich das vorstellt die letzte zeit
ist das haus auch tatsächlich im
dornröschenschlaf versunken oder hat es
doch auch bis zu drei für das team das
hat die krise abgehakt hat das hat aber
wie sie richtig sagen viele kolleginnen
kollegen wo es geschafft hannover das
neue programm digitale angebot
erarbeiteten figuren danken wir selbst
andrea spielmann und wie das genau
wusste hat die letzten tag beim
landesmuseum wie der betrieb langsam
wieder gefahr wurde ist das haben wir
mit der kamera begleitet
[Musik]
das landesmuseum beherbergt viele
raritäten neuerdings 900 leiter
desinfektionsmittel nicht einfach zu
beschaffen es zu den von ihr
historisches ihre ganze klasse und jetzt
eben reichlich in einer situation dass
wir über eine seriöse material haben
desinfizieren
ein großes thema auch für das
aufsichtspersonal was ist jetzt erst ich
und vergangenheits klavier beruf stelle
geht oder vier tische stellen verteilt
auf alle uhr stellige mit babys von
hygiene distance wegen gut vorher
bereich der kritische punkt aus marmor
alle besucher empfangen
ich glaube es selbst nicht gerade hufe
audienz klinsmann der als controller von
ist eigentlich immer live 12
überblick wer wo etwa sind was platz
etwas zeit
[Musik]
in der neuesten ausstellung geht es um
nonnen aus dem mittelalter deren
handschriften lange warten mussten um
wieder aus dem loch dann geholt zu
werden
[Musik]
da sind einfach die montage woman
vorbereiteten die buchstütze sind
vorhanden und ihre blicke zu und licht
ausschluss und wartet auf mit der quick
zweiten historischer manuskripte die nur
beschränkte zeit dem licht ausgesetzt
werden dürfen
heikel ist corona nicht nur für
handschriften sondern auch für den
einsatz von touchscreens
das problem lösen wir das auch jene
stifter dieses spezielle ausgleich für
touchscreen zeigt das jetzt mit dem
stift alles machen wo ich normalerweise
wird mit der hand machen dies insofern
überrascht es dass jetzt schon losgehen
mit dem juni kraft und haben
dementsprechend gekauft und stellt
lieferte sind zum teil längerem er hoffe
dass jetzt wieder rechnen die hansestadt
ist durch ständige märsche stockfisch
alte hygienevorschriften sind vor allem
bei interaktiven ausstellungen ein
problem wie hier in der gameshow wie der
renault strebe stiefel und ausprobieren
um setzt sich für eine lange und wie es
original objekt sind um in die netze
putze verteiler mit der kutsche mit
ausnahme von den stationen wo man brühl
hat da funktioniert das leider nicht
wieder auf dem kopf hat über die augen
und über die nasse und darum den
medienbereich leider spüren
ein haus mit über 7000 quadratmeter
ausstellungsfläche corona sicher zu
machen ist nicht ganz einfach
[Musik]
da braucht es die kontroll visite des
museumsdirektors höchstpersönlich der
gardine
ich finde die findige gut also dass ich
so einfach weil du hast information
zusammen desinfektionsmittels findet per
funk haben wir mehrere vorteile
ja ja ja stimmt dem du machst so denn
ich sage das ist so viel wie gesucht
ein museum bereit für seine
besucherinnen und besucher in
schwierigen zeiten
andreas pielmeier die eu ständig über
sie einfach zwei weine tabelle eröffne
das brauchst ja bestens der rückzug
enthaltsamkeit cannabis lernen sie
vielleicht ganz seriös oder die spieler
sind expertin xi für home office
identisch versammlungsverbot terminen
und gold das sie ein könne zwar holz und
zusammengesetzt um zusammen hatte aber
wo mir die ausstellung machen die ist
eine pandemie irgendwie zu diskutieren
sondern eventuelle ganz toll die
außerordentliche persönlichkeit aus dem
mittelalter wieder vorstellen und zeigen
was möglich ist für ihre frau im
mittelalter musik aus dem eigentlich
alles machen was ihr am abend ein großes
im landesmuseum sich sammlerobjekte jede
epoche von der geschicht wird also der
mundschutz der wald als objekt ist
inventar aufgaben ja zum beispiel wenn
man könnte die rote krawatte von daniel
koch vom normalerweise und immer vor der
pressekonferenz oder rau wie gaben mit
humor haben besondere zieht was lauf was
gibt es auch cartoons was geht's ab
filme und natürlich eben eine medizinal
bereich beispielsweise beatmet sport mix
geräte mit schweizer produkt hamilton
zum beispiel soll bis sie stand mit
einem haus auf und identität vom land
und die täter vielleicht wichtiger denn
je wer sie mir wären sie über ihre
grenzen definieren wir sind die samen
institutionen aufbauen hand
demokratische institutionen politische
prozess dass er selber zum beispiel des
pandemie gesetz gibt
das wahlrecht gibt es abstimmen das
recht geht und alters schafft bindig
schafft emotionale bindung zu der
gesellschaft zu der gemeinschaft die
thermal abt und das geschieht mir jetzt
eben aamodt wie loyalität und der
solidarität gegenüber der gemeinschaft
die frau etwas bewegungsfreiheit jetzt
eine tagesreise frau im landesmuseum was
bringt die zukunft
die macher der ausstellung und die heißt
der erschöpfte motto natur geschichte
von der antike bis heute
und das hat er das fazit ist erschöpft
das haben wir einen kaffee und verstehe
oder das kuratorische 60 des staates
werde man ein wagnis und kataloge
herzlicher dank andreas böhme gern
[Musik]
für ein teil des kulturellen lebens
erwacht also wieder aber wir werden
dieses jahr auch auf vieles verzichten
müssen das zürcher theater spektakel
wird wenn überhaupt nicht im gewohnten
rahmen stattfinden können konzerte
lesungen all das werden wir bitterlich
vermissen was für die kulturschaffenden
eine existenzielle bedrohung ist
bedeutet für uns einen extrem rüden
sommer ein abgesang die filmfestspiele
in lokalen das gurtenfestival
die thuner seefestspiele das zürich
openair
es wird dann leiser sommer
großveranstaltungen sind allesamt
verboten
millionenverluste für veranstalter und
test es pur für das publikum
denn für hunderttausende sind festivals
und andere kulturveranstaltungen
schlicht lebensqualität auch im
sittertobel bei st gallen wird es heuer
still bleiben keine beats kein tanz
durch die nacht für fest über leiter
christoph huber ein alptraum
mit 17 jahren wie 187 mich sehr stark
und den besuch auch lange ich auch ins
gehen dürfen will anfang schaffen
über 20 jahre es ist einfach ein
fixpunkt im leben
also ich passe sich damit sie ganz ganz
viele jahre
ich will doch ich kann nicht sagen der
schweizer shooting star aber wie im
letzten jahr
es klingt wie die ankündigung einer
großen wehmut die viele befällt für die
festivals viel mehr sind als nur coole
events nämlich mit post ceo videos
verlegt wo womit lehde tor wo aus sie 20
drehs klar das thema geäußert und das
ist für sie den fixpunkten der fall
auf der facebook-seite des openair st
gallen findet sich ein brief geschrieben
von der radio moderatorin lisa pillinger
einem zehn jahre gelernt
dann ist erst mal um die tobisch aber da
ist noch lang nicht alles
ich habe dir holen dafür bleibe gefunden
[Musik]
für mich ist immer im herzen in großer
nähe
was wird sein die zukunft von festivals
dieser art bleibt ungewiss
geplant wird zwar für das nächste jahr
aber kann man die b zum buchen
wird es überhaupt wieder tourneen geben
wird man reisen können wird die
infrastruktur designfestival benötigt
überleben
der branche sind wahnsinnig viel viel
einfährt wir haben eine ton firmen
involviert wo ihres geldes so viel
geändert und nun gab der gesamten hand
von der event branche
das ist nötig linie branche man wird
immer wieder gesagt es ist ein luxus
dass ich glaube soziale kontakte
untereinander ist mindestens so wichtig
wie die gesellschaft eine wichtige rolle
und die wird auch wichtige zukunft sie
das zurich film festival ist ein
gesellschaftlicher anlass
es lebt vom glamour der stars die nach
zürich kommen ob und wie es 100 corona
krise betroffen sein wird weiß derzeit
niemand
der neue feste war direktor christian
jungen gibt sich kämpferisch es plan der
das cola gibt wie man hört in teilen der
abn amro mehr arbeiter sind aber für
häusliche zwiener mond mission geschafft
mir sätze wirklich auf der physischen
los wir setzen darauf dass man
stattfinden kann
wir stehen dafür bewegung fürs comeback
von kino vor der wechsel von netflix zur
bellevue von 30 hose zum smoking vom
individuellen vielen konsumieren zum
kollektiven vielmehr laden ist und ich
glaube dass man das festival gott nach
der krise fürs comeback fürs kino
wichtige rolle spielen könnte
zürich spielt nicht die erste geige
unter den filmfestspielen
solange nicht klar ist welche großen
festivals stattfinden welche filme dort
welt krimi haben werden bleibt auch das
programm für ziemlich unsicher wähler
status hat der premiere haben wird
europa premiere haben jetzt
welt-premiere oder können wir nach
toronto und venedig ins spiel und so
lange nicht klar ist was mit venedig und
toronto ist für uns extrem schwierig im
film können bestätigen will natürlich
die produzenten wie zerstört was die
anderen festival entscheiden während
zürich noch hofft musste das
dokumentarfilmfestival in leos sich in
diesem jahr komplett neu erfinden
warum die festivalfilme nicht im
internet zeigen sagte sich die leiterin
der visio reality budgets sogar die
preisverleihung fand online statt
während die kinos in neo leer bleiben
mussten hat dieses konzept funktioniert
das ziel erreicht einfach der zugang zu
den digitalen screenings war auf 500
zuschauer begrenzt
man musste sich entscheiden viele waren
schnell ausverkauft 60.000 mal wurden
die filme gesicht mehr klicks als ganz
reale besucher im jahr davor
[Musik]
und wie er findet man andere digitale
festival formen
diese frage stellt sich auch hier auf
der landiwiese am zürichsee
vogelgezwitscher oder theater spektakel
im sommer kann man hier die welt neu
entdecken wenn das theater den blick
wagt in andere kulturen auch in diesem
sommer
fragen wir den leiter des
theaterspektakels matthias von hartz
also wir gehen davon aus dass das
theater spektakel in seiner bisherigen
form so nicht stattfinden kann
das war das uns aber ehrlich gesagt auch
schon seit wochen klar dass sich 5000
leute auf der landiwiese treffen konnte
man sich ja schon länger nicht mehr
vorstellen
und deswegen arbeiten wir auch schon
seit wochen daran mittel und wege zu
finden die internationalen künstlerinnen
und ihre perspektiven trotzdem nach
zürich in die schweiz zu bringen
es wird stattfinden das theaterspektakel
noch nicht so wie wir es kennen schon
immer verwandelte es die landiwiese zum
öffentlichen theater raum und zeigt
produktionen aus aller welt
matthias von hartz reist um den globus
welt projekte aus und unterstützt
koproduziert mit anderen festivals er
kennt die prekären bedingungen in den
ländern des südens denkt zum beispiel
konkret an der choreografen aus mosambik
wo ich auch im herbst war und gesehen
habe wie dünnen die struktur ist in der
die künstler vor ort arbeiten
die brauchen dringend eine
internationale sichtbarkeit und
umgekehrt würde ich sagen wir brauchen
es im moment dringend geschichten von
dort zu hören wo unsere nachrichten im
moment nicht hinreichen die sich ja auf
eine erschreckende art und weise
nationalisiert haben neue formen sind
gefragt denn festivals sind nicht nur
sommerprogramm
sie eröffnen neue perspektiven einen
anderen blick auf unsere welt
[Musik]
während auch die schweizer filmbranche
ist weitgehend außer gefecht gesetzt
aber einige schweizer regie schaffende
haben den ganz kleinen teams in den
letzten wochen kurzfilme gedreht und
einen kleinen vorgeschmack dazu sehen
sie nach mitternacht auf sf 1 wir gehen
nächste woche der frage nach ob die
korona krise alte rollenmuster zwischen
mann und frau neu zementiert hat bis
dahin
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos